ccsd police releasing this dramatic
video of a school police officer firing
shots at a car with teenagers inside
school police say two officers were
responding to reports of a fight in the
parking lot when that all went down 8
news now reporter victoria saha has been
following this story and has more
[Music]
this all unfolding a week ago at the
western high school parking lot where
two students were struck by bullets as
they did not listen to officers orders
and sped through the parking lot
when we first spoke to the students
involved they told us they were trying
to escape a fight that broke out on
campus after school this video shows us
the car they were in it is a black ford
fusion circling around the parking lot
hitting a student then trying to drive
away this is when you hear the officers
telling the driver to stop and then the
school officer pulls out his weapon
stop the car
at that point fearing for his safety the
safety for students and his partner
officer christopher knight discharged
the service weapon three times
the car accelerated out of the parking
lot through more students and then
exited the parking lot headed eastbound
on bonanza we are now learning one of
the juveniles that was shot was the
driver who went to umc to get treated i
ran into his family outside the hospital
last week where they say they did stop
the car but the body camera video shows
otherwise lieutenant zinc says this was
the first officer-involved shooting for
school police since 2005. he also says
the students involved are not enrolled
at any ccsd schools the car was going 22
miles per hour but the speed limit on
all school property parking lots are 5
miles per hour and there was a gun that
was found inside the car in the studio
victoria saha live local now